even when it seemed like there is no
chance I was determined to not stop that
last day every second mattered I
basically had to be
hyperfocused and be really calculated
about what I did with the time I had I
don't care about any of these punches
anymore you can hit me another hundred
times I'm not going to stop this
47-year-old guy with a full-time job
just did something absolutely
unfathomable you ran 450 M over 108
hours 4 and 1/2 days the Big's backyard
Ultra basically setting an entirely new
bar when it comes to human capability
how we see ourselves is one of the most
important things in the world I've been
running ultas for like 27 years now I
didn't even know that was even feasible
we are also capable of such incredible
Feats no matter what your Pursuits we
mostly can go so much further than we
ever see ourselves going what is the
engine that gets you through four and a
half days without sleep and is
continuing to propel
[Music]
you today's episode is brought to you by
the awesome organizations that make this
show possible
[Music]
Harvey Lewis back in the house wow it's
uh like a dream so good to see you I
can't wait to get into all of this
you're such a delightful presence we had
fun just chatting with you and Kelly
who's here as well who might pop in a
little bit later we'll see a lot to
unpack but let's start with when I saw
you last which was couple months ago in
rural Georgia at an event called Running
Man that our buddy Jesse ller put
on you showed up for a day you joined us
on stage for a panel you traveled from
your home in Cincinnati you had been
teaching were you teaching earlier that
day or the day before the day before the
day before you came out showed up did
the deal had happy to be there then you
went back home to Cincinnati to teach
because you never miss a class and then
you traveled to B Buckle Tennessee God
knows where that
is showed up for another round at Big's
backyard Ultra and towed the line with
just three hours of sleep is that
correct do I have that right uh yeah the
Sleep aspect of the 3 hours happened
later in that week it wasn't tied to the
Running Man festival but it was uh a
busy week and it was a busy week also
with teaching and my mother moved to
Maryland so then I had to move some
final items out of the house on like
that uh Thursday night like before the
next day where I went down to Tennessee
after my classes and so it was a it was
a busy week you know I was in the first
day of the race I was thinking did I
maybe push a little too much going down
the Running Man not exactly an equation
to set you up for Success at you know
perhaps the biggest race of your career
maybe yeah maybe you're like stacking
the deck against yourself maybe but you
know the thing was so powerful was
getting to be down there with you guys
and it was such a cool experience going
in in the saunas I had such great time
doing the sauna and then just being in
the sauna and like meditating on what's
coming and just the energy that we had
down there with like the panel and the
questions from Chris uh just
really sent me off with a lot of
positive energy the the people we ran
into down there that we're at the
festival that just were excited to be
out there participating for me it was
electrifying to get me going to the next
weekend yeah a little love letter to
Jesse and uh his compadre with the all
day Running Company they put on this
extraordinary event that was a couple
hours West of Atlanta like near the
Alabama border and it was essentially
Coachella for people who are into
running on this incredible plot of land
where there was all kinds of food trucks
and experiences and a main stage with
all types of panels that's what we did
but in addition to that like musical
acts and running races of all kinds and
everybody was sort of camping in tents
on the perimeter of this field and the
kind of highlight of the whole thing was
the world's largest sauna that was
literally like you know bigger than this
I mean it was I don't know how many
square feet this thing was but I think
there was something like over a dozen of
the ovens or whatever you call them
inside saas and people lingering around
in that and then going back and forth
between that and all these other kind of
saunas that were peppered around the
field and these cold plunges I don't
even know what is it I can't think of
anything else to compare it to really it
was wild I mean it was crazy and and uh
yeah the and then you had the giant
sauna and then you had some uh smaller
ones that were even hotter and I just
remember going into the really hot sauna
and then going directly from that to get
into the cold plunge and I don't know do
you do a lot of the cold plunging I do
now yeah I've got one at home and I've
got a I've got a sauna now also that's a
recent Edition I love it just got those
fantastic I've had a plunge for a while
they've been a great support to me and
they just released their own sauna so we
just had that hooked up and online so
it's pretty great to have that at home
it really is you know sort of physical
benefits aside like mental healthwise
like it's really been a great addition
to my routine I agree with you so much
there was also like a trailer that was a
cold room yeah you know like I mean only
Jesse you know he is a Bless yeah I mean
he goes to 's degree for sure I texted
him earlier and asked him if he had any
questions for you so I I wrote those
down I'm going to hit you up with those
and we should definitely FaceTime him at
the end oh that' be a blast but in any
event uh that's still you know an energy
expenditure on your part to show up and
be around a lot of people and and you
know give everyone your love and and all
of that I mean it's the side aspect of
your part-time job not to mention your
full-time job as a high school teacher
but I remember leaving that event and
you know I needed a day of rest after
that you know and I just went home and
got back into my you know daily routine
and you had all these other things that
you had to take care of before you
showed up at this enormous race to throw
down just this absolutely alltime
legendary performance yeah it's hard to
say but that that whole event definitely
brought some momentum into bigs as well
and it was the energy from the people
that I I just took in so much positive
energy well let's not assume that
everybody watching or listening to this
enjoyed our first episode and spend a
moment to just explain what this whole
Big's backyard Ultra thing is so that
everyone understands what we're talking
about yeah yeah so basically this is is
a race that began in this rural area
Tennessee uh that was created by the
iconic uh race director LZ Lake Gary
kantrell uh he uh basically came up with
this Vision about 50 years before he put
it into action when he was back in high
school and he dreamed up well I'm not
the fastest person on the track team but
I sure can run a long time and I think
if I could just have a race
he was thinking to himself where every
Runner had to cover 4167 miles which
equates to 100 miles over 24 hours then
I think I have a chance of maybe winning
so self-serving this idea yeah Les is
great great characters of all time in in
sport or just in general I mean he is an
enigma and fascinating for so many
reasons people may be familiar with him
from the Barkley
Marathon um documentary that I think
it's on Netflix is it on Netflix it's
free now like you can look on YouTube it
used to be on Netflix and uh it's uh the
the race that eats it young right so I
mean it's a classic almost like a cult
like following of the film and stuff and
like around Barkley Laz is full of many
contradictions and
Mysteries uh and he's just an absolute
wizard when it comes to his his writing
and with this race he puts out usually a
new post every hour I don't know how he
he manages to do that where he'll like
describe you know what's happening in
the race you'll like take some element
of it and it's really interesting to
read how he puts it into his own words
he's sort of a a mashup between a
backwoods survivalist who's living like
Off the Grid mixed with this kind of
philosopher king sensibility to him that
is confounding because he doesn't appear
to be someone with that type of
intellect but I think wasn't his dad
like a NASA scientist or something like
that yeah his dad was a a NASA scientist
and he helped to engineer The Landing
for the lunar module wow yeah yeah many
people might assume that he's just like
a hillbilly living up in the hills but
he he scored a 36 on the act so he had a
perfect
score so he's quite for a long time he
yeah he was accountant and he also
coached with the local sports teams for
years and years and years and one of his
greatest dreams in life is to give a
million dollars in charity and I don't
know his entire accounting for that but
I wouldn't be surprised if he's already
surpassed that with the race he put on
during the pandemic this uh virtual Race
Across Tennessee had over like 20,000
people sign up for it and uh but he's
really
someone who gives a lot to the whole
like ultra running uh he he just adds so
such a layer of additional
like races like I mean he's got all
these he's got like eight different
races and they all have some unique
element to him right so the bigs is a
race that takes place on his property
right it's like it's 150 acres that he
owns so he basically he doesn't have to
get permits or anything like that it's
like on his own private land right it's
actually named after his dog big right
who he rescued a big giant
pitbull uh dog head showed up on the
front of his uh land uh
shot and when he first saw it he thought
there's no way this dog is going to
survive and he end up living to be 16
which is really old for a big dog he
just passed away last year but this race
that began in
2011 has now spread to 73 three
countries and there's more than 400
backyard alas across the globe and in
addition to that now more people hit uh
running uh 100 miles under 24 hours in
the backyard format than all other 100
MERS last year combined it's astonishing
but also not surprising because it is a
brilliant conceit essentially you're
running a Four Mile and change loop on
the hour every hour everybody starts at
the same time and people you know kind
of fade away when they can't make the 1
hour time cut off until there's just two
people left until that one person falls
off and then there's a winner and the
winner has to then stop they can't
continue which is an added little
interesting Quirk because if you win a
backyard race the other competitors
aren't quite sure how much was left in
the tank so even if you you said oh I
did this many laps or whatever you can't
really gauge
whether they were able to go further
which creates a little bit of a question
mark when you line up with the world's
best for this kind of thing right and
then the the second thing that I think
is really
interesting is that first of all
everybody gets it like you can
understand this like even if you have no
connection to running you're like okay I
understand it it's sort of like a game
show it lends itself
perfectly to a format like television
where it's gamified in a certain way
right and this year there was a live
stream I think there was when you won
two years ago also right yeah yeah two
years ago Solomon actually set up a film
team uh and then this year uh a
videographer from France Fabian he
actually had a whole team there so I
mean it was it's quite incredible they
had like drones and honestly I really
just loved having the opportunity for
people to be able to see the race
transpire yeah and so like you know once
we entered into the woods there were
only like maybe three standing like
cameras that that were not like uh you
didn't really even notice it much uh
once in a while there would be someone
with a camera kind of like run into the
woods falling behind you it was nice to
know that my students and my family
could like see what was happening you
know uh versus just hearing third hand
like what was going on in the race so
like I I felt like I was connecting with
people back home by having that there in
most of my Ultras like throughout this
entire year there's not been any other
Ultra I've ran where you have that sort
of like video coverage right which was
amazing yeah so the coverage from your
point of view was relatively unobtrusive
and you had had this experience two
years prior so you knew okay this is
being documented but the live
stream was handled extremely
professionally like they did an
incredible job and I don't know how much
awareness you have around this but as
somebody who is watching from afar and
kind of following Along on social media
and checking in on the live stream there
was a ground swell movement that took
place probably in large part due to
Jesse's just unbridled enthusiasm
because he was on Instagram constantly
on stories like you gota everybody's got
to check out this live stream you have
noidea a what's going on there's never
been anything like this before like he
just was going on and on and on and
there was a ripple effect where all
kinds of people from all over the world
people who have no connection to running
let alone ultr running were hopping on
board and sharing stories and spreading
the word about this event that was
taking place as it was sort of mounting
like as it progressed like not just on
the last day like on day two and a half
it felt like it really hit like a
pivotal threshold and it became like a
mainstream thing I don't know how many
people were watching this live stream
but it was a lot and I just
noticed the larger World jumping on
board to celebrate this incredible thing
that they'd never heard about before
which of course after your
Victory translated into all kinds of
mainstream press like you got an article
on CNN and in the guardian like that
must have been
surreal to you because this is an event
even amidst you know Ultra events that
is so rooted in the history and the
organic nature of what ultr running is
like this is hey man there's no frills
here there's no prize money this is not
UTMB like this is like as you know
Backwoods As It Gets By Design By laz's
very design and yet it captured the
imagination and the fascination of the
world
it was something I'm speechless about
even now the race format is like nothing
I've ever seen before in the sense of
like it just uh causes like this growth
of like people following it each day
more and more people follow it and I me
I once I got home in Ohio like there
were people coming up to me in my city
and say like I don't run but I got
addicted to that I didn't get any work
done yeah people people a lot of people
are like man I was supposed to work
today
watching the show like it's a
Christopher Nolan movie or something
it's so funny and then people come up
they be like man I would go to bed and I
would wake up the next morning and you
guys are still running like what and so
yeah this particular race format it just
causes this continual build build build
of of more and more people kind of
seeing what what's going to happen now
it's sort of like if Mr Beast was
designing an ultra race right this would
be it right I'm sure your students are
all Mr Beast fans right or it's the
ultra distance version of squid game
basically right yeah nobody dies well I
guess they could but like you know
nobody's trying to kill anybody and we
have Kelly here who actually was a
contestant on the reality TV show
version of squid game yeah and I was
saying to you beforehand like there's a
weird Vin diagram overlap between you
two because there is some shared DNA
with yeah you know somebody who would
sign up for something like that and what
you do yeah yeah we definitely train
together and we have like these kind of
quirky ways we do training uh sometimes
like for this squid game we we we kind
of anticipate that there would probably
be this red light green light game so
we'll be out running in the neighborhood
and hopefully the neighbors weren't
watching but we like i' like all right
red light it should have to stop and
like hold her pose and then yeah we have
fun with it it's nice to have a partner
that's like kind of shares some of the
ures together so you ran 450 mil over
108 hours four and a half days and
completed this race just before 7 o' on
October
25th previously two years prior you had
done 85 laps right yeah how many miles
was that 354 354 you won that we talked
about that last time um but this
is a big difference 85 and 108 laps is
that 108 laps right well that's right
that's not an incremental Improvement RV
as wild you know it's very interesting
like this race actually happened from
2011 to 2021 no one had gone over 300
miles um this year 22 Runners went over
300 miles which is incredible so what do
you make of that the whole equation is
uh it's important to look at every
single Runner so we had 75 Runners from
like I guess about 45
countries and so it's really important
the every Runner matters in terms of the
final distance that's able to be
achieved and it's wild how that's uh the
case but it is because the more Runners
who make it further it pushes more
Runners further and the next Runners
further so we had six Runners who made
it to 400 miles which is really
phenomenal and then we had ehore who
made it uh and pushed me to as assist to
450 right I want to talk a little bit
about him uh he certainly is deserving
of quite a bit of Celebration young like
he's like 27 I think yeah absolutely so
in many ways you know perhaps the heira
parent to this little subculture right
it'll be interesting to see how he
develops over the years oh yeah and he
Canadian Ukrainian right yeah right he
lives in BC actually we did a race
together in Alberta in August is the
Canadian Death Race and it's just an
iconic place on the planet Grand cash is
about four or 5,000 people and you go up
and down about three pretty sizable
mountains but he beat me in that race by
two hours right yeah and he almost he he
just missed the the record on the course
which is the old course the old Ultra by
just minutes and it and it's pretty much
because they had a mismarking on the
course which caused him to miss that I
saw a quote where La said something like
it was a standoff at the very end
between the
clearly stronger Runner meaning him and
the guy who just won't quit meaning you
right right so how did you emerge
Victorious I know there's an interesting
story around the lap that preceded the
final appp that involved the little
mental H
Janks there's so much to the whole thing
um cuz probably at some point want to
talk about the sleep deprivation yeah no
we're to get but yeah that last day was
uh just a matter of seconds like every
second mattered and so when it got to
like we were beyond the world record and
there were like four or five Runners
still left then I knew I basically
had to be
hyperfocused and I had to be really
calculated about what I did with the
time I had so I mean I was just
finishing laps at that point like by
maybe five minutes like so 55 minutes
and in this course in this race uh of
course you that gives you five minutes
to possibly do what you want to and you
have to be back in the crow when the
whistle goes and uh ready to go again so
in that four or five minutes I was like
laying down and putting my feet up
getting ice on my body because it was a
warm day and I was even taking like
60-second naps like not every hour but I
did take a couple 60-second naps cuz I
was so tired I could literally just fall
asleep and it felt like gold to me like
I was like wow I get up 60 seconds later
I'm just so thankful I can get 60
seconds of sleep oh my God yeah so when
it got down to uh BOS uh the Polish
Runner and eore and I there was like
three of us uh then you know there were
some signs I saw of BOS just a
phenomenal Runner he said something to
me he said like I I wanted to go home
you know he said like at one point and I
knew he was kind of like uh on the edge
of like he went further cuz I think he
said at one point I'm just going to go
one more lap and then he like said oh
you're still here it's like another lap
beyond that so he kept going but I could
tell like he was really starting to feel
it and E after the race people told me
that they had seen that he had said some
things in front of the camera but I
didn't know any of that like in terms of
like you know maybe his foot was
bothering him I was just so focused on
just getting myself reset with that 5
minutes and like not falling down on the
trail that I was not like
entirely like I was just focused on
making it just keep going I wasn't like
really reading everything he was saying
at the time but the lap previous to the
Victorious lap didn't you sprint off the
line and you know try to like you know
screw with him a little bit like Yeah by
putting in like a huge effort all of a
sudden well no maybe like the that was
the last lap I think I went off but
maybe I did do it that lap too I
basically got in front of front of him
in this course there's like a 300 M 400
m on the road before you uh enter the
woods so I went off the line pretty
quickly but he caught up to me going
down this hill on the road and then he
was in front of me and I passed him
going up the hill and when I passed him
I ran really fast back through the The
Starting Gate and at that point you know
I was really determined to give it a a
strong lap and part of that was I wanted
to reset anything I wanted to do for
like the road laps because that was the
last trail lap but also part of it was a
send a message that like I'm still here
you know I'm not I'm not going anywhere
and that was kind of my logic and he had
a little trouble so when he got up there
I don't think he saw me run through the
camp really fast but I know he like had
uh you stopped for a moment and was just
like maybe teetering on the idea of like
you know what's my purpose of continuing
at this point and LZ said to win go get
him uh and then he went and to his
credit he ran a very strong lap and came
back around and so you we wouldn't have
gone out to the road had he not put in
that effort I he almost caught me on
that trail that lap nevertheless so why
do you think that you were able to beat
him ultimately you're saying uh well you
know one interesting thing about that in
that whole race that was the first lap I
finished first across the whole 107 laps
like I had never done that in that
particular race at that day that's
interesting and it's own right it is
there's a psychology to that what did I
beat him with it's hard to say exactly
but uh I was determined to not stop I
mean everyone that went there had some
idea of one wanted to go really far and
I would say at least a couple dozen
people wanted to win the race and had
similar ideas that I did but I just
never lost that idea that Vision I just
even when it seemed like there is no
chance like all the odds are stacked
against you uh especially for example in
like day one and day two like I was
really feeling tired day one you said
was your worst day you felt the worst on
the first day yeah actually day one and
day two like we're I was more tired and
I knew I was more tired than any
previous year i' had done the race so
like knowing where you space in your
head right you're not supposed to feel
this bad this early you're not supposed
to feel like I'm I'm like well I
remember the 2021 year and when I was in
day two I was just kind of like felt
like I was almost floating and I
remember this year and I'm like oh my
God I'm feeling kind of tired here you
know it's like I feel the tiredness
maybe I should have got running maybe I
should have got the running man maybe I
shouldn't have been like moving things
on Thursday nights maybe I should have
taken a day off from work versus driving
down after work on Friday um there were
a lot of things that kind of went into
my mind in the night before the race one
of the three worst sleeping nights ever
I only got like three hours of sleep and
I woke up at like 2:00 a.m. and I just
laid there and I just my mind was like
thinking about everything I couldn't
calm my mind down and I couldn't fall
back to sleep so I went to the starting
line knowing that I only got 3 hours of
sleep going into the race that I will
need the most amount of sleep of in my
whole life so it is not a good omen per
se and then in the first three days I
didn't sleep at all like I actually laid
down and I really believe there's a true
physiological and mental impact from
just laying there with your eyes shut I
could say maybe it's like 60% or a
little more than that of the same
benefit of actually sleeping cuz if
you're awake it's different than just
laying there with your eyes shut um but
I couldn't sleep at all for 3 days and
so it wasn't until the fourth night John
N and I another uh American runner from
our our team he and I were running
together and uh I was doing like 55
minute laps and we we just got to this
point where I was able to like fall
asleep for like two minutes and it just
was like oh my God this is the best
sleep I've had in my whole life like
just sleeping for minutes because going
for 3 days with no sleep was that by
intention that you weren't going to
sleep for the first 3 days or that's
just the way that it played out no it's
just the way it played out like I
practiced sleeping I talked to uh Todd
at the uh Running Man festival and he
had some really great ideas about how to
like you know breathe before you fall
asleep all these things were really like
things that I should have done better to
practice that element leading up like
for a couple months but yeah in my my my
training at lunchtime I'd go and lay
down for 5 minutes in my classroom
you're trying to train yourself to fall
asleep quickly I would fall asleep I
could literally do it in my classroom I
fall asleep 3 minutes bam get back up
even like on runs I did like running i'
go to the park I'd like lay down in the
middle of like the park for like three
five minutes and get up but when it came
to the race I was just so worked up and
then after like day two I'm drinking
like Tailwind and cocacola and drinks
that have caffeine in them so I mean
that probably also like added an element
of not being able to fall asleep it was
my dream to want to fall asleep and like
sleep more than ever before because
there's another story I'll share about
it in Australia with that whole like
Madness of not getting enough sleep go
ahead share it okay so basically I was
in Australia this summer and we did this
uh incredible race Tim Walsh uh dead Cal
golly Tim's got this Ranch in the
country of uh Queensland goes back to
1877 so it's kind of ironic that a
Rancher you know he he has like a a
cattle farm would would recruit a a
vegan from America to come and run in
his race but yeah he was just a
phenomenal guy his race attracted like
uh Runners from New Zealand from South
Africa and the top Runners from
Australia so uh the race went uh to a
new world record which was kind of
interesting because this is just a race
that no one had really heard of outside
of Australia too much and we were able
to push it to uh Phil Gore beat the
Belgium record and Sam Harvey was his
assist so those two guys and I was the
third Runner what happened to me is I
made it to 375 miles and I was uh again
struggling with the sleep and also I had
gotten really dehydrated in in the
middle part of the day so for about 10
hours I hung on by literally like
strings just getting myself into the
Corral with like minutes to go at 375
miles I finally uh tapped out and I told
our Runners we were out in the middle of
the the woods uh on the road I said you
guys best of luck to you as soon as they
went off like 50 meters I started the
greatest hallucinations I've ever had in
my whole life like the most incredible I
never had anything even remotely close
to I mean I had seen Shadows that I my
brain interprets as other things but
this a whole another level it was like
stranger things like the grass became
grass people there were the trees were
alive the whole Forest like the sounds
like were super acute and then I would
like sort of fall asleep for like just a
millisecond and I wake up like this as
I'm standing there I wasn't scared I was
I was totally aware what was happening
but it's just like everything was an
absolute huc ination right that was just
strange I never experienced that running
your brain's releasing its DMT into your
system were you running while that was
happening no I had paused I was just
walking and kind of like talking to the
woods like oh my God like actually if I
go back to that place ever again I'm not
sure I'll ever get back to that again I
think I can actually run through that
like I think it would just be like a
wild experience but I could just still
run through that whole thing you're like
a
psychonaut exploring the outer edges of
sleep deprivation
right the science is in people hot and
cold therapy in other words using sauna
and cold water immersion has so many
powerful benefits like lowering
inflammation reducing muscle soreness
boosting energy and elevating mood but
the thing is DIY ice spaz are this
colossal Hassle and basically just
impractical making the whole Affair un
sustainable which is a problem solved by
the guys at plunge who pioneered the
all-in-one solution this gorgeous
elegant modern tub that's easy to
install indoors or out with Cooling and
filtration built right into it so it
basically requires almost zero
maintenance and I use it almost every
single day which has greatly impacted my
physical health and I got to say vastly
improved my mental well-being the plung
team now also offers a beautiful sauna
for the ultimate hot cold experience
this gorgeously designed addition to
your space I got mine up and running
recently and I got to say I can no
longer imagine life without it it really
has been an absolute GameChanger for my
physical health of course but also all
these profound benefits to my mental
well-being to learn more and get your
own cold plunge tub or sauna visit
plunge. comom and hit the link in the
description below and use code Rich Roll
to get $150 off your
purchase
showing up only on 3 hours of sleep then
not sleeping for the first three days of
this whole thing and then all told like
your cumulative sleep for the entire
bigs four and a half days not count of 3
hours before would have been like maybe
like 20 25 minutes 20 25 minutes total
for four and a half days four and a half
days yeah something like that and I
didn't have even a single hallucination
like during that whole period I don't
know what happened I mean I didn't in
2021 I would sort of hear sometimes
noises like someone's running behind me
or I would see some sort of light and
I'd like interpret as like a dog or
whatever I didn't even have that like in
this one I had like no hallucinations
but on the fourth night I did start to
go into this like phase of being like
sort of running sort of dreaming so I
would fall asleep and like trip a bit
and somehow I didn't ever fall down on
the road this race which I didn't
mention if someone's just tuning into
this for the first time you've got 11
hours on a trail and then it has 13
hours on the road the night time you're
on the roads at night exactly so on the
trail the trail is more difficult like
there's 450 feet of climbing you have
rocks and roots and you have areas that
if you fall you're going to possibly
hurt yourself pretty good on the road
you have basically maybe
150 180 foot of like climbing and
descent
and you have an out and back of 2.1
miles so if you fall you're just going
to scratch your elbow or your knee or
whatever in that mode I was starting to
like go into a different mental state at
times like with John running next to me
I would start to like say things that
didn't make sense like I was like I
don't have streaming services and like
tell me like I remember saying that I'm
like why did I say that like I was and
John would be like what are you talking
about Harvey it was just like uh this
like flow of thought that just like you
get in the dreamlike state where you're
that's very interesting it's like it's
like you're dreaming but you're awake
and so like your flow of thought is just
uncontrolled like it was I was not in
any control of my flow of thought many
times in that fourth night and in fact
at about five hours into the fourth
night I I said to John I was like how
many of these laps have we done and he's
like I think like uh two and I was like
yeah I think two as well and we looked
there watch just wow we've done five of
these we forgot like where' they go I
don't know where went so that was
something totally new to me I mean I've
been running Ultras for like 27 years
now I didn't even know that was even
feasible to do something like that and I
mean I saw somewhere in a publication uh
where you know you get some like
different feedback from different folks
and someone said like well Harvey really
was impressed with what he did with some
of these things but like that sleep
stuff was just total luck you know and I
was like well you know the funny thing
is is like really none of this is really
genetics or luck a lot of it really is
uh building up like your endurance and
like when I first started doing this uh
when I was 20 I ran a 24-hour race and I
can remember like the hardest thing of
that 24-hour race was surviving the
night I remember getting up 1:00 a.m. 2
a.m. 3:00 a.m. and it's like it's
something that is like having a car on
top of yourself you're like trying to
just stay awake with everything you have
and so it took many years and these
backyards I can remember going back to
Courtney ey in 2020 where I tapped out
at like 270 some miles and that that was
like a large part of that was building
up like the ability to endure like that
sleep deprivation as well could you have
imagined then that there would be a day
where you would go 180 miles further
than that no way no way I mean honestly
when I first came to that race it was
was so funny because they were handing
out the race numbers I just remember
them saying like yeah well maybe like it
was just meant as a joke like maybe
someone will you I think it's going to
go to 300 miles and like uh everyone's
like no no it never do that and I
remember back to when I was running
these 24-hour races and I thought I
would really love to run 130 miles and
that seemed like some Giant Mount
Everest so far away there's an
insurmountable for myself at 20 like I
mean that was I ran 81 miles like in
that 24-hour race and I mean it took me
5 years to get to Breaking five hours in
a marathon it took me another like 14
years to get to Breaking three hours uh
from that point so 1 years to qualify
for boss mean your whole life is an
ultra it's like a life's commitment it
you know it's not just showing up and
suddenly you have this capacity or this
prowess that you you know you didn't
even know that you had you've been
working on this for the better part of
your entire
life yeah it's been a long journey it's
definitely been a Ultra experience and I
love like The Count of Monte Cristal and
like that hammering through that that
tunnel and like uh we all have tunnels
in life and we all have something to
hammer through and just that's where I
was at when I finished when I was on my
last Loop in in The Bigs this year and I
was coming back and I knew at at the
moment where I actually saw there was no
ehore and I was like I cannot believe
that this was a dream that I had for so
long and for this whole year it was
something I really just envisioned so
strong but it was like the probabilities
of getting there seemed so infinite
testly small when you thought about like
all the competition all the the runners
all the things that could go wrong I
just had to like say a prayer and like
just slow down and like uh just soak in
the energy of like my surroundings and
then just be grateful for having that
opportunity what do you extract from
that about human
capability that is the place uh that we
are all so capable of such incredible
Feats and no matter what your area of
specialization or what your Pursuits we
mostly can go so much further than we
ever see ourselves going and it's so
important where we see ourselves how we
see ourselves is is one of the most
important things in the world so I mean
for example I always envision myself as
well I'd love to be a fast marathoner
but I always envision myself as being
like maybe for a long time it was like a
4-Hour marathoner and then somewhere
along the line I thought well I start to
see myself as maybe a 3:30 and then
maybe 3:15 and then I well maybe I can
be a sub three hour and then I was like
well wow maybe maybe I can be so I got
to
245 58 and now I'm like you know I'm not
sure if that's like my Pinnacle or maybe
I can actually go further than that even
though I'm at my age right now 47 it
seems
counterintuitive and I have my PR is
from four years ago you know maybe it is
actually possible if I concentrate my
energies and and also adopt like the
knowledge that's available to make that
happen is that on the bucket list to try
to go back to the marathon and and just
throw it down and see what you can do I
think I'd love to do that yeah I'd love
to do that I think uh this year I'm not
sure about this year I've got a lot of
things on the agenda a lot of races uh
but I would definitely like I wouldn't
want to sacrifice the ultas I'm doing
now but I think it's actually possible
which I've done in the past I've always
gotone faster in the marathon at the
same time I'm getting faster in Ultras
and a lot of times people think oh it's
not possible because if you're working
on 100 mile race no way you're going to
get faster than a 5k or a marathon but I
think it's actually Poss possible to
perhaps have them work side by side
however for like getting sub 245 I'll
probably have to dedicate myself for
like maybe three and a half months or
three months to real specific training
but yeah I would love to do something
like that maybe maybe like want hit 50
or it' be super interesting you could
you could literally just discard the
weekly long run like you got like I got
the endurance part covered all I'm going
to do is go to the track like three
times a week and just throw down you
know 400s at race Pace or whatever and
just forget about any dist stuff
whatsoever and just fine-tune some speed
and try to get your Tempo up to par and
then just show up you know I think I'm
GNA need your uh your son your C plunge
yeah some coal plunging might be
involved um I gotta ask and I'm sure
you've been asked this many times but
again back to the Quirk like when the
other guy doesn't show up for the next
lap you
win but the story that isn't quite told
is how much further you could have gone
could you have kept going and if so how
much further do you think you could have
run how many more laps Loops whatever
you call them laps Loops yeah you could
yeah yeah it's laps yeah we call them
actually yards yards yards technically
yeah you know I got into this incredible
space in the fourth night like uh I felt
like I found some sort of frequency with
running and I feel like there's a
mathematic equation to it and it's like
with pacing if you hit a certain Pace
Mark in your
Marathon uh you can go so much faster
than if you miss it by like your mile
splits by even like 10 seconds you can
throw that off so I feel like I hit some
sort of frequency where I just felt like
I could go forever but uh there are so
many things that can go wrong as well so
by the time I I hit that fifth day of
running on the road I definitely felt
like it was possible we could have just
kept on going that whole night uh
because only major impediment possibly
at that moment would have been like
sleep
deprivation but I felt like it was
possible so we maybe could have gone
back to the trail for a uh fifth day I
guess it would be yeah so then you would
have the element of the trail again and
so like that can be tricky like I mean
if I didn't fall at all the first three
days that I can remember um but the
fourth day I fell a bunch more and I
started falling like the more towards
like one two three and afternoon cuz
your depth perception thrown off from
the St deprivation yeah I was wearing my
road shoes on on the trail so I also
like beat my road shoes up at that
moment cuz I had worn them through the
night where I like falling asleep and
like on the road but I was also we him
on the trail so that probably also
didn't help things but yeah you could
entirely not knock yourself out by
Falling on some rocks or something like
that like my my did like in 20121 and
then also in 2021 I fell down on the
third day and like just fell poorly on
my hand I'm really good at falling I
fall a lot but but I fell and broke my
hand so this time I was really good
about my falling it just uh you have to
be so careful because there are any
particular points if you're not getting
uh enough nutrition every hour then
you're just going to like MH you're just
not going to be able to go so I mean you
have to like constantly be aware of your
like nutrition you have to be aware of
like uh your pace in yourself you can't
get like overly carried away like I was
maybe showing at the start of lap I
wouldn't want to do that like a Sprint
through the whole Loop you know and one
trip on a route go down and you're out
you could yeah so you have to be really
conscious of what you're doing so I feel
like it is definitely possible that we
could have gotten back to that fifth day
and then I feel like it's possible to go
beyond that too so I I really didn't see
any finish I was just going to go until
the last person so I mean I I was
prepared to just go you're not going to
lay a number on the table here 550 what
we about Harvey as far as 600 I think
that a lot is possible I think it's it
may be possible to even do something
like that W for sure yeah I think it's
possible a lot of athletes in these
multi-day events suffer from all kinds
of digestion problems the stomach gets
upset they can't hold calories down and
that ends up you know basically you know
toppling the best of them but you didn't
seem to have any kind of issues with
that despite taking in something like
40,000 calories or however much food you
ate over the course of this 4 and a half
day period like to what do you attribute
that and is that also something that you
practice and try to train and prepare
for most definitely like I can remember
being out on the course and hearing
other Runners like squabble about
digestion issues like maybe I don't know
what percent I heard at least 10%
complaining about yeah some digest
digestion issues so it is a big big big
impact to be able to like consume 300 or
more calories every hour and then I mean
40,000 calories across four and a half
days like they that's a lot of calories
yeah I mean that's incredible amount I
don't really practice it like uh in
terms of like my monthly routine of like
training it's like these races help to
inform that so like doing bad water in
the summertime where the temperatures
are over 12 20° I get a real good sense
of like what I can consume at any
temperature possible I mean I've done uh
races ranging from like bad water in
2021 I think it was like close to
128 to like the arrowhead
135 which you know that race can get
down below zero quite far uh so it's
like more than 10 some degrees of like
temperature range and uh with
bigs the plant-based foods make such an
incredible impact like not having the
dairy or the meat it's easier for my
body to digest things quickly so I'm
able to digest more calories quicker and
if it's warm out that's where it's also
you know definitely going to help you
even more because I don't have like any
issues with like the speed of digestion
and the inflammation too like that's
another thing I I know you're at least
another Runner I they had to actually
change their shoes uh so like cuz their
feet swallowed up so much they had to
borrow another European shoes uh for
size 14 and a half I think that they
started in like a 12 size so I mean it's
like I don't know if that was entirely
attributed to like the nutrition um but
I can say when I do see other Runners
like I know that they talk about like
swelling their lower legs um near their
shins and ankles and I didn't have any
type of swelling in the race during the
race point I had no no swelling that was
visible so like that has an impact on
like minimalizing your your risk of
injury and also like impacting your
performance I try to eat foods that are
easy to digest so I'll eat like lots of
fruits but I also have like soups with
noodles I'll have like avocado wrap with
like hummus I have like uh lentil soup
so I'm also getting protein in there if
I'm only running like a 100 mile race
I'm like have zero care about like
really all the dynamic of like the
makeup it's more important like the
number of calories I'm getting like salt
and fat uh but in these longer races I'm
also being more mindful about getting
protein and like a race over a 100 miles
like especially bigs that I'm trying to
eat something more than just a gel or
like a Tailwind
I'm also trying to get like some real
food in Me Maybe as much as like every
two hours but I know a lot of Runners
would have difficulty doing that if they
didn't get practice with that but I've
just been doing it for years and years
and years so I mean maybe if I think
back to when I was doing that in my
early 2000s I would come back and just
like oh my stomach is like roaring but
I've conditioned my stomach to be able
to like just eat a burrito from Chipotle
and then just go yeah it's like kind of
wild how you can condition your your
body and your mind to adapt talk to me a
little bit about the recovery we're not
that many years distanced from a period
of time in which conventional wisdom was
if you ran a marathon then you should
pretty much you know take the rest of
the year off because it's going to take
a long time for your body to bounce back
then we enter this world of Ultras and
then the idea being like well if you're
going to run a 50 mile race 100 mile
race like maybe just that once a year
you my friend competed in 10 Ultras this
year and not just like we're not talking
50 kilometer races we're talking
insanely long distances and you seem to
have this preternatural ability to
bounce back and be right back on your
feet back teaching back running into
your daily routine without more than a
blink of an eye after a race like this
so walk me through what is going on here
kind of gotten a full formula but
movement is really important so for me
like the day after a race I think even
getting out to walk for like 20 minutes
is like dynamite compared to if you were
to not do anything at all so some sort
of movement is is critical daily to our
self-existence like I mean I know this
from like breaking my neck back in 2004
from that experience I didn't take any
painkillers after I left the hospital
hospital and I was feeling a lot of
discomfort especially the first like
week but what I found was like not
moving was far more painful than moving
my body and walking so walking is
actually like lotion to your body like
it is like it is incredible so with
these these races I do like one mile run
after the race kind of keep my run
streak although that kind of like the
same day or the foll day next day all
right
and then I I basically am not going very
fast I mean it's a slow mile it's like
usually over 10 minute mile and uh then
I'll like just build on to that so if
it's like a a shorter race like maybe a
100 mile race maybe I feel pretty good
and I'll just go run like you know three
or four miles or I'll run to work three
miles run home from work three miles I
have like that run streak to work is
like 10 and a half years now without
missing a day without missing a day 10
and a half years 10 and a half years
running to and from and from work every
day I love it I honestly say like well
if someone were to offer me if I I'd
have to give it up for a Ferrari I would
like not take the Ferrari I I love the
Ferrari it's very nice car I have a hard
time seeing you in a Ferrari that feels
like very inac you know
District we saw one last night we were
having to debate about what kind of car
it was I was like that's a Ferrari and
Kelly's like that's not a
Ferrari but the motion to is like lotion
it's real critical like movement is so
important for our bodies whether you're
able to do it at a higher level with
yoga or uh you're just simply making a
walk like that's powerful in itself so I
mean that's another thing with like I
think uh ultra running and top athletes
um in different genres I don't think
that walking is too valued like in terms
of like maybe I'm wrong but I don't I
don't see a lot of Runners talking about
hiking and walking all the time um but
for me I feel like walking I try to
incorporate some level walking
especially when I'm training for like a
big race like walking in the woods is
really fantastic and I value that we're
walking with a group of friends in the
city we have like a Thursday I get
together with some of my friends that
aren't Runners and we just do a walk
it's really nice like that was one of my
best training buildups to bigs was
getting together with my friends who are
not Runners and like doing the walk with
them because some of them uh my one
buddy Charles he's a professor
economics and he's he's been uh you know
struggling with some of the health
issues over the last few years and uh
trying to get his weight down and so for
him it was really powerful to be able to
get the walk in and for me it also was
powerful for me because I'd already done
all these miles running and getting that
walk-in was like getting that last pump
in like a bench press it was like give
me that extra little extra it's like
that 1% that that an
impact in terms of the training how
structured is it you run to and from
your school every day uh and then you're
competing in these Ultras which are part
of the training I assume but is there a
program is it periodized do you have a
coach what does that look like or is it
just something that you figure out and
go on feel it's like the wizard of a
that guy behind the scene pull no cuz
honestly I don't you have Chris house
like sending you a program telling you
what to do every day I've never had a
coach my life never had a coach no no
and I think in some ways uh you know
Courtney and I are very similar in some
domains when it comes to training like I
don't have a a definitive plan for each
day like I kind of leave it flexible so
for example today I had no plan I I just
know I want to get out there and and use
the time I have and so this morning I
woke up uh kind of both woke up about
4:30 and I was like oh you know hey I'm
in this beautiful place I'm just honey
I'll be back in a few couple hours and I
went up the mountain I didn't know I was
going to do like the mountains above
Agora Hills this morning but it was just
perfect for like to get into the Barkley
s and being nighttime dark still and
like getting some like verts in it was
phenomenal but I didn't have it on my
agenda it's just like trying to work
with what I have however like I do know
week to week I know like I want to get
this many miles or I want to like build
this much climbing in so I have like a a
weekly plan and then I have with races
I'll have like a pyramid plan in my mind
like that I'll I'll kind of trace it
backwards so I say okay like two or
three weeks out I want to be at this
point and then I build it backwards and
I say okay where am I here okay so I'm
going get from here to that that point
what do I have to do to get from here to
there and then so I'll just gradually
build up the mileage and I'll also be
thinking about like each race I want to
simulate what's happening with the race
so for Bigs it was like combination of
half the time Trail Half thee time road
so I can't just focus only on one or the
other I have to be strong in both and
also I don't have to be that fast like
for Bigs it's just about being out there
and surviving the longest so getting
used to running at not the fast this
time or doing the walking with my
friends like I'm not doing that right
now in my routine although I wish I
could but just tweaking things so that
it fits whatever race you're going after
and that's one of the things I love
about ultra running so much is that it
has such diversity there's so many
things you can explore you could go for
really fast race on a track or 50k or
road race or you can go out and like do
a stage race in like Mongolia or
something I mean there's all sorts of
things you can do so I've never had any
coach but I have people that are like uh
have inspired me right including
yourself no come on no it's true but
there is a there is a level of
intentionality that you're bringing to
it and to your point about the
similarities or the shared sensibility
that you have with Courtney you know I
look at the two of you and I think I
maybe talked about this last time you
were on but I see very similar
personality types as well you're both
incredibly aable grounded humble people
who are grateful to you know be doing
what they're doing and almost seem
bewildered by their own success on some
level and I can't help but think like
what is that about like what you do and
what she does together I mean you guys
are at the top of the mountain in terms
of you know human capability and ultr
running but I have to think also that
behind the scenes there's some sort of
hidden engine here uh that I'd like to
know a little bit more about but I think
your dispositions are so generous and I
think it dispels maybe somebody who
doesn't know so much about this world
dispels their preconception that in
order to do the kind of things that both
of you do that you have to be this
really hardened person who's a take no
prisoners type of personality and you're
not that like you're a very kind of
loving open you know graceful gentle
human being what is that
about well Courtney is much more humble
she she is she is I greatly appreciate
like the compare you know compare me at
any way to Courtney because Courtney is
uh just the best in the world in so many
domains and she true and 450 miles okay
so keep going go ahead I think like the
basic one of the things about Courtney
and I is that even if we weren't like
winning races or even finishing the
first front half of the group I I think
we would still be out there enjoying the
experience we're both very competitive
people but we also I think that the base
energy which we operate is that we we
just
love the whole piece we love running we
love the people we love the the nature
so I mean I feel like and there's a lot
of people that have those same energy
forces that that propel them but I feel
like that for us it's not just about
being uh the first runner we're both
very competitive and we strive to be the
best we can be but I hope that even
someday you know hopefully it's many
many years and decades from now but
someday when I'm finishing in the very
back I'll still be out there and
enjoying it you know uh having fun with
uh just whatever that endeavor is or
Venture is like it's just an adventure
so I think that to me there's more
important things in in life um it
resonates with me the adventure of it
all is something that I
it's Priceless to me like there's
nothing so I'm just grateful to have
this experience it's it's just for the
young person under my layers that was
chunk and Goonies yeah that that was you
know working for years to get under five
hours in the marathon you know I never
saw myself as a strong runner in middle
school or high school yeah I never saw
that it wasn't as uh disciplin with
things uh I I didn't know that it was
even feasible to to grow into that sort
of mode I guess I took it as like uh
more genetics or that it was just not
feasible to your point a lot of people
share that sensibility with ultr running
the appreciation of the community being
outdoors nature pushing yourself like
all of that stuff is not unique to you
nor to nor nor to Courtney no so I guess
you know the question remains like what
is it what is the
differentiator for you is it the
accumulation of all of these experiences
and the level of discipline and
intentionality that that you've kind of
brought to this experience incrementally
over a long period of time what is the
difference between you running 450 miles
and the person who craps out at 300 250
whatever like what is the secret weapon
under the hood if I pop the hood you
know into Harvey's Soul I'm very driven
like uh with the run the thing he like
behind the smile and the the affability
is this is what I'm getting at there has
to be some kind of Killer Instinct deep
down under there that try to hide from
everyone I'm not as I'm not as where's
the darkness I'm not as Pacific is
courney she is she is she is there's no
Darkness there I tried I tried to find
it I couldn't I couldn't Earth but I am
bad I use my imagination in sort of uh
some wild ways at times and like uh you
know like I I have like the honey badger
spirit animal mhm um you got a couple
Spirit yeah I have a couple to this race
I was H it was a honey badger like the
honey badger just never stop choose your
adventure spirit animal like you you
swap them out I do yeah it depends on
the environment but it only happens for
like my big a races so next one will be
Barkley but it's the honey badger the uh
Mongolian horse cuz Mongolian horse just
keeps on going and I would be like in
the midst of the race i' be like going
like that cuz it relaxes your face it
helps relax your shoulders is actually
has a it's a technique that the horses
use and run they do that yeah that's so
I think
so I'm making that upal the yeah it's my
theory but the runners would be near me
and be like Harvey what are you doing
that like that like uh I'm like that's
my I'm just like relaxing myself you
know it's like I'm a Mongolian horse
yeah and Courtney has like a a dragon uh
like thing but I'll have to let her tell
you that because it might be a
secret but yeah I've never heard that
yeah Dragon divulge something that was
she could she could tell you technique
but you also have an unlikely spirit
animal a third one do you know what I'm
talking about the dragon I don't know no
no no well there's monarch butterfly
thank you yes so the first day in bigs
actually kind of took on the monarch
butterfly because Anthony from Quebec is
a friend of mine and he ran from Quebec
to Mexico to draw awareness he's he and
his wife are attorneys they took time
off from their practice and they want to
draw awareness about the plight of the
monarchs because that's their Mig
migratory pattern they fly from Canada
to Mexico all the way yeah I mean it's
incredible on a single life cycle to go
all the way from Quebec to Mexico
they're trying to get people to plant
milkweed there's like a a loss of
perhaps 90% of the monarchs and there's
also a group that come up here to
California too that there's a real loss
of these but anyways I saw a monarch on
the first day when I was running and
that was
absolutely uh that gave me a little
Spike of like energy you know just like
just to make that connection with my
friend Anthony and like monarch
butterflies don't seem like the proper
spirit animal for this sort of
Engagement
counterintuitive go like this for 15
what's interesting about it is that it's
this tiny fragile thing and yet it can
go all the way from Canada to Mexico so
it's defying your expectations which
kind of plays into this personality type
of you being this you know kind of
affable guy who is living your life who
has this
capacity that uh he can unleash at any
moment and defy everybody's expectations
that's magic of it and there are some
other things too so the week before the
race I I think I went to Whole Foods on
uh Thursday night with Kelly she came
down for a night from Circleville and
anyways I ran into this old lady um back
by the serial is and she kind of remind
me my mother she had her this real fancy
hat on and she was lonely I felt like
you know and I wanted to just strike up
a conversation and I said like oh I love
your hat and this and that and then we
got to the checkout aisle and this lady
happened to be behind me I was wearing
my two time JW gear and it has a big X
here and she looked over at me and it's
like you know week before Halloween and
she's like are you an X-Man I was like
well kind of so I'm a 2X man twox so
then in midst the race I have to be
honest like on the second day I did have
like this sort of uh moment where I just
like was envisioning myself as Wolverine
and I'm like all these other Runners
because there's 75 Runners it can be
really intimidating that all these
people are like very strong and look
fast and all the other things and I'm
like you guys are all gone it's bad of
me to say but yes I had that moment
where why is it bad of bad for you to
say that you feel guilty like owning
your space and planting your flag yeah
so I'm just like yeah everyone you guys
are all you're you're in for something
coming yeah it was bad the storm is
coming the storm is coming he like in
the form of Wolverine in Wolverine I'm
like yeah in the terms of running like
I'm just going to run you to down
there's an interesting psychological
thing about the alter ego like when you
step out of the frame of who you think
you are and you step into the you know
exoskeleton of a superhero there is an
energy boost with that like it is a
common thing whether conscious or
otherwise that you know tons of high
performers do I mean there's a
difference between David goggin and
goggin you know or Mark Cavendish and
Cav or James Lawrence and the iron
Cowboy there's a million examples and I
think there's something very intentional
about having that moniker or that
archetype that creates like another gear
for a performance that the Harvey might
not be capable of but the Wolverine or
the monarch butterfly or the honey
badger uh or thean horse use every
single tool in the toolbox yeah so a
wild thing cuz when I'm in my classroom
I mean I'm I'm trying and I'm I I give
my full effort but there are days where
I'm like I want to step into my
character that comes after four days you
know it's like I build into this
different being of myself at times where
it's like I'm very calm and subdued and
relaxed and then but there are times
where I was out there on like the fourth
day and I don't know who else was
running near me I wasn't cussing at them
but I had like a soundtrack that sound
like David gy it's like a bit so I get
into like different modes it wasn't
complaining it was just like psyching
myself up yeah just G myself pyed up it
is an interesting thing I think using
your your power of your
imagination and
creativity and like when I didn't put
myself in that Wolverine character like
every day it was like that second day
and I sort of smiled like and laughed
about it and it just actually like was
entertaining to me it was like just kind
of fun and it also kind of propelled me
later that night I probably felt maybe I
was really tired like on the second
night that was one of my my tougher
points and I like said to my buddy Randy
because you're only allowed to have one
crew member there but my buddy Jud was
doing a DJ event in
Indiana so we were allowed to have uh my
crew trade on the third day he's like I
love you Harvey but I'm out of here I
got to go spin some records yeah he's
like well my one friend Randy had to go
go to danis appointment my other friend
Jud he had to come from like doing that
but Jud is an amazing crew person I
always say like with these events the
crew is like quintessential in so many
ways with Randy he also like was able to
say something powerful so like the
second night might have been like maybe
it was even the third start of the third
day it was a simple point he said he's
like uh one of your team members uh
Kevin he was on the USA team the year
before and he was also running a race
it's like the film crew asked him who
they thought would be the last person to
survive and Kevin's like you know
without a doubt Harvey and so my my
other bu told me this it caused some
sort of physiological change even in me
like I felt like that fatigue and and
tension I was feeling like that was
going through my back and I was just
feeling really tired and a little bit
stiff it was like that just went away
and I felt this like new energy and I
was like want to like live up to that
expectation there and like also it felt
really good that Kevin said that like it
was really such an incredible compliment
for him to say something like that about
me CU I my mind was always teetering on
like losing that faith and I was always
trying to keep that that dream of being
the last person going the the furthest
cemented together but there were many
times where I had to really fight to
keep it from crossing over the other
boundary you keep that that positive
mindset that it's still doable when I'm
going for 3 days without sleep and I'm
feeling more tired than the previous
year and it's like but then by the time
I got to the fourth night it seemed like
I got to that frequency where I was so
uh hellbent on like being the final
person I like lost a sense of like
fatigue to a degree like I those things
became less visible to me like my brain
was so hyper laser focus on being the
final outcome that all the other things
just didn't matter anymore I was like
you transcended fatigue I transc a
different state of consciousness was a
different state like I I went through a
metamorphous where it just left me I was
like I was fighting it like it was like
when I was in with Jesse and the cold
plunge after doing the hot sauna and I
got in that cold plunge I'm not the best
at the cold plunge yet like I'm in there
for 20 seconds and I'm like
just like this and and Jess is like just
relax into it just relax into it relax
your breathing and I mean I only made it
like 30 some seconds or whatever but um
the whole experience you kind of
transcended over to bigs with like you
get to a point where you relax into it
and then it's like you're anticipating
like the punch coming but once the
punches have come you're just like well
I fuckets I don't care about any of
these punches anymore you can hit me
another hundred times I'm not going to
stop so it just pulls you and that
that's where it really attracts me this
because I I can't get to that sort of
place and running a marathon or running
a 100 mile race this takes you to a
whole another place I've ever seen
before yeah that's so
wild uh yeah it's it's something that
can't even be described in words like
it's so experiential it's like trying to
explain to somebody what your Iowaska
trip was like right like you are a
psychonaut in that regard like it is as
much if not more a venture into the
Beyond of you know the brain's capacity
and the relationship between
Consciousness and physical activity like
in a new and different way that isn't
just about the typical conversation
around like walk me through your mantras
when you reach that point where you
can't keep going like this is the PHD
version of that where you're almost on a
different plane and a different
relationship with your own body and
level of self-awareness because the
fatigue is so profound it's like a point
of opportunity to like I feel like
there's some sort of there's a
Enlightenment that does come from like
this this period and like uh exploring
those spaces of the human mind so what
are you returning to report back to us
mere mortals about what you learned from
that you know yeah what is this doing
for you part of our DNA like I feel like
you know as humans we are driven to the
unknown there is a point of death so I
mean things are not you cannot
infinitely go forever but in a human
evolution and in our our time on this
planet humans have experienced those
points before I mean you look at like
Feats of surv survival uh the six days
the man trapped under the rock I've lost
his name right at the moment but oh the
one they made the movie about he had to
basically break his arm off yeah I mean
it's just an incredible story or or
someone lost at sea for weeks I mean
it's like uh those are far more
remarkable but it's like pushing to that
same uh that we have more in us than we
realize and like the very interesting
thing was like after the race I sat down
we had like a little celebration and I
did some chat on like with the live feed
and then I walked um over to the like
tent with my my buddy Jud and another
friend next to me and I mean I walked
but I was relying on them a bit too like
I mean I was definitely like and my body
was like yep we're done we're done this
is it um but the the thing that's wild
is that my mind I really believe I could
have just run through that whole night
and I think that it's possible that
maybe we could have kept going through
into the next day and then how far
beyond that I'm not sure but in terms of
my body my body was just cooperating
like at that point my body surrendered
to my mind my body just gave up and it
said I'm I'm tired of resisting this
brain you know and it says we're going
to go we're just going to go as far as
we have to and there no debate about it
we're just doing it but the minute the
race is over and you're like I'm done
everything shut down then it goes back
to the body gets majority control right
and then it's like no we're going to lay
down we're going to take our time we're
going to go to restroom over there we're
going to take one minute to walk to that
restroom on the subject of higher ples
of Consciousness and and the kind of
transcendent aspect of this it feels
like a natural race for you to pursue
would be the
3100 is that on the list did we talk
about that last time maybe we did I
can't remember actually have you ever
had a guess on from that right uh no
well I had Sanjay raal on who made the
documentary about it and I know people
who have competed in it it's not a
backyard format but it's not dissimilar
it's like a stage race you have certain
hours where you can run and you just run
around this city block right that's only
a mile Loop right and how do you say the
name again it's sh it's the
shinoy sh Shino yeah because I think
that he is a fascinating character I
mean he pulled airplanes by himself I
didn't know about this yeah like he's
the one that developed that race uh he's
since passed away yeah but he's like the
patron saint of running especially in
New York City he he's had a major impact
on running culture dating back to you
know the early 7s I think really
interesting spiritual leader and who's
the guy the New York Ted cor road
runners well there was Ted and then
who's the guy who ran the New York City
marathon in like the 70s and 80s I can't
remember his name but I believe I could
be wrong but I believe he was heavily
influenced by S Shin Moy and there's
such a strong running culture in New
York City and I think you can't
understand the origin of that culture
without understanding Shri shinoy who is
like this spiritual Guru right who had
this philosophy that running was a path
to transcend
rning and that's the origin of this race
the 3100 where you run around the city
blocking Queens totally
nondescript like not Urban but not
Suburban kind of City you know layout
until somebody gets to 3,100 miles right
and and hopefully self transcends in the
process of that all right so right this
has to be on your bucket list yeah it
would be it's uh it's in a summertime so
it's almost possible will do with my
teaching schedule but uh you know I did
learn from like the appalation trail
that when you do a really long adventure
like that even with my like methodical
way of like eating plant-based
Foods movement hot and cold treatment
it's it's difficult to bounce your body
back in like six months it takes maybe 6
months or eight months so it would take
some time but I I'm I love the you know
the
exploring that that does sound like it
could be mhm it's a lot of time it's a
lot of time commitment for sure I mean
it's basically like your whole summer
fall I think I was I was in New York
City I think it was October and it was
going on while I was there so it goes
into the fall that would cut in I mean
you're it's tough you know very
committed to not missing a day of
teaching well I do miss days and I think
that everyone my school is very like the
rest of staff are probably like Harvey
why you how you get to take all these
times off I take it unpaid Le and
fortunately like I do get the time off
but I usually uh take maybe two weeks to
do races in the year that race is like
also uh involves I would feel like I
like having crew members also for these
big events and that would be a major
commitment to be away from Kelly and uh
or to have I don't think she's going to
want to come longer like few days or a
week maybe to that kind of race but you
know she could she could shack up at a
nice hotel in Manhattan and pop in every
couple just make sure you're still alive
yeah there's actually right now I have
on my uh Instagram under Stories the
opportunity to vote for one of my races
for
2024 and like going back to 2017 when I
did bigs For the First Time The reason I
decided to do bigs is I put four
different races out there I had like a
Six-Day race a a stage race in Oman
maybe it was like Leadville and also
bigs and bigs won like with 80% of vote
so that's why I did that race the first
time I would have never discovered it
had like people not vote here's what's
going to happen you're going to do this
again and I'm going to campaign I'm
going to lobby for the 3100 and then
you're in big
trouble right but let me ask you this so
you have a full-time job teaching we
talked about that at length last time
and Ultra running is also a full-time
job I don't think it would be fair to
call it a part-time gig like you're very
serious about this obviously you're at
the Pinnacle of your career and
Performing you know at the highest Elite
level but your life is full and I'm
interested in how these two worlds
nourish each other because I would have
to assume that if a brand came to you I
don't know you know shoe brand or an
apparel brand and said Harvey we just
you're the best we love you we think
that you are the the hero that we need
and the Ambassador that we want on our
roster and we're going to write you this
enormous check and we want you to just
run would you take that deal if that
meant that you had to retire from
teaching well I have this amazing shoe
company already behind me with Newton
honestly I am so so loyal to them I've
already been offered something that
maybe seeds that by quite a long
distance but I've been with Newton for
over a decade and like I truly let's say
it's a non-competing brand I know you
love Newton it's great and I want you to
$100,000 let definitely love on Newton
for sure let's say it's a food brand or
Whole Foods comes to you and says we're
Amazon we're just name your number
Harvey right would I do that we know you
like that Ferrari you can have that too
well honestly I would probably be open
to doing that for like a leave of
absence so like for a year or maybe for
a few years but then again like after I
I I really love the teaching aspect so
if I if I went that direction I did that
then I would want to also be doing
something like relatable to youth as
well so then I would have to like uh
start a program like Ray up in um Quebec
uh he's a hop uh he has H yeah right he
has like a really neat neat Adventure he
takes kids uh several times a year to
like these remote places on the planet
and then they they broadcast what's
happening for like lesson plans with
like Canadian National Geographic and
it's like then he's into the classroom
so he's impacting more than just a
single classroom he's impacting
classrooms all over so if I had a a
dream like I would absolutely absolutely
love to be able to impact more kids and
be in more classrooms that's where I
would be oh see the opportunity with
that but with my school SCPA it's a it's
a really amazing place it's a very
diverse like art school like what your
children have and it's hard to replace
that but if I were to have an
opportunity where I could do something
in that respect of like you could scale
the impact scale it to a larger that
you're having on young people I would
100% be in or or if I could do like a
sort of running travel TV show or
something what's stat of that cuz I know
you you're trying to make this happen we
got to talk to Kelly on that she she's
kind of helping I want to bring Kelly on
but I have one more thing I want to uh
talk to you about before we do that
which is the why behind all of this I'm
sure this is another question people ask
you why do you do this what are you
getting out of this why do you have to
run so far and I just know in the course
of kind of sharing your story and the
stories of other people who are on the
outer edges of you know this world that
amidst the celebratory you know kind of
response that you get there's also some
push back from people who are like why
are you sharing this this is unhealthy
this isn't good for anybody like these
people must have some kind of
psychological problem like why you know
like like there are better people to
celebrate there's something not right
about this and maybe you shouldn't be
promoting it right right I'm sure you
get a little bit of that com oh yeah
definitely so what's the why and you
know what is really driving this behind
all of it yeah I mean is it maso that
has the hierarchy of human needs like
sort of paralleling that like I I feel
like there's a hierarchy there so I mean
at the base level it's like there's like
a physical element to it like a a
chemistry like a dopamine impact you
know like from like running what running
brings you positive health and brings
like positive like you know feelings
both while I'm doing it as as well as
like in the afternoon when I'm like
reflecting back on that experience but
then there's like the social aspect like
I mean I've met uh people that have
overcome numerous life challenges
because of running and it's like part of
that is also that social Dynamic like
what they get from like being a part of
something so there's that social Dynamic
that's large and you get the sort of
like Elation that comes from like
beating yourself like to to push
yourself to another level and to uh
continuously be even when you're in your
your 60s your 70s or like my friend Mike
Fremont who's 102 in February right
friend of the Pod still kicking still
kicking out there getting it done he
does pull-ups every night on his way to
bed it's like and he he wears your shoes
not my shoes on he Li he lik yeah he
wears ons and he he collects the little
Pebbles uh he's got a little like a jar
that's about this big of like the
Pebbles he's collected from the Sho that
get stuck in the all yeah he likes to
bring it back to the shoe store and like
give them back but it is like a a love
um there's like um a spiritual element
to it as well like once I recognize like
the highest points it's like I feel like
a closeness with the energy of the
Universe I don't know what to say I
can't really describe it but I feel that
like power sometimes when I'm like in a
in a event like bad water out in the
middle of the desert and I can see you
know for as far as human I can see and I
just like take my body and just It Feels
So Primal to be moving across that
landscape and doing things that my
younger self was thought was like
absolutely insane so that's something
but then there's also at the very high
level there's also like this giving back
so like this year we actually teamed up
with the Brighton Center and like we
didn't finalize everything that was
another thing I was working on the last
eight days before R the last the last
eight days before the race I was like we
had been talking about but we didn't
finalize the details and we were going
to aim to raise
$100,000 which was Far 10 times more
I've ever raised for any group uh I got
to speak to the people working on the
ground this organization helps like over
20,000 people in Northern Kentucky
Greater Cincinnati it's like Family
Planning right it's everything they have
shelters they have like uh food banks
they have like help people get their
first houses to overcome like addiction
there's all different like facets to
this organization but are nonprofits and
so it was at that point it was also
another drive like knowing like when I
have my friend Tracy Outlaw who does all
my social media like in these races and
this a really good Storyteller but he he
was relaying to me that we were up over
$155,000 and we over
20,000 and that gave me more motivation
as well so I mean we end up raising now
over 40
$4,000 so I mean it's like knowing that
that was connecting with other people
and and knowing that we were impacting
other people it impacted me and like
that that was also like motivation in it
and also like I really love to like
influence our culture around Health in
in Ohio we're not uh
really at the same level California uh
we have even you know a higher obesity
rate uh feel like there's fewer options
for healthier foods especially in rural
areas like Circle where Kelly and I live
I live half my time in Circleville and
so I kind of like honestly like when I'm
running to work and back home from work
and I'm racing the buses I kind of
consider myself like a human billboard
so it's like trying to get people to
move Beyond like uh you know what they
can do to to you know take the people
that that are more sedentary and get
them out and like walking I mean I try
to do that with my students that is
something that I I try to do I try to
encourage people to eat more Whole Food
plant-based Foods you know even if
they're not going to like you know
become vegetarian or vegan like I mean
if they're incorporating more of that
into their nutrition you know my mom had
a stroke when she was like 54 and she
almost died and as a result of it it it
impacted Her speech and her Mobility for
the rest of her life and fortunately she
is still alive at
ad4 but for 30 years it's been a a
different experience like she you know
she does not have the same uh abilities
and it's very frustrating for her so I
mean much of what happened to her at
54 could have possibly been different
had she been eating differently and had
she been uh had a routine and had less
stress in her life you know those those
things absolutely I don't believe she
would had the stroke so I feel like you
know DNA does play a role and it does
impact us but we can ALS fight back and
like we can also you know I have an end
date as well but it's like the quality
of life like I mean my buddy 102 Mike
Fremont he's still doing pull-ups at 102
I mean that's remarkable how many people
can do a pullup I mean across the whole
population that guy's unbelievable yeah
he went 102 I mean he came to my
classroom he walked up all four flights
of stairs I mean and like it's there a
lot of people come into school that
don't do that they are 20 and 30 years
of age so I mean to me like I'm only one
person you're one person we have a whole
bunch of people out here in ultra
running and like different like
activities like this but I feel like if
I can influence uh a few people or more
people I would that would be the best
thing in my world like you know just to
have more influence and getting people
that higher quality life so it's not an
inconvenience it's a it's far from that
all right
answer complete yeah I'm sorry your
answer I'm sorry
I no I want to hear you I want to hear
you out right and you can get Kelly up
here to hear the honest truth of it
trust
me that's coming she's coming in hot in
a minute but before we get to her I'm
not going to let you off the hook on
this if I heard you correctly your
answer to the question of why you do
what you do and push yourself in this
very specific way
is because of the community social
aspect of it your love of nature this
feeling that you get from pushing
yourself and kind of suffering and you
know the kind of Downstream impact that
that has on your life the spiritual uh
piece to it then we have the fundraising
piece and then there's this role that
you can play in terms of influencing the
health of others all very laudable wise
and yet I'm feeling I'm feeling like you
didn't we're not quite there in terms of
getting to the bottom of this I think
that all of these goals could be pursued
short of running 450 miles and not
sleeping for days on end you could go to
the Turkey Trot and maybe run the New
York City marathon every other year and
still raise money enjoy the social
pieace get out in nature have a you know
a spiritual experience and and the
like if I was going to create my own
maso's hierarchy of these wise I think I
would put in terms of like your pure
honesty in answering this question I
would put the spiritual piece and the
suffering piece at the top here because
those are the two that I think might be
inching a little bit closer to the
answer of why you go as long and as hard
as you do because all of these other
goals can be achieved short of you
practicing five minute naps in between
classes and you know spending every
commute for the last 10 and a half years
running to and from school all the like
it's very extreme right admittedly I get
it bro I love you but right to the
person who is the person who's posting
like I don't understand this like this
is like let's go a little bit deeper
here let's get into the darkness like
what's the real push like what is what
is the engine that gets you through that
third day and into the fourth fourth day
and into 4 and 1 half days without sleep
and is continuing to propel you beyond
your enjoyment of Nature and it's cool
to hang out with some other people when
you're running around in the
woods well I mean I just I'm not saying
you have to I'm not saying you have to
know the answer to that it's a it's a
yeah you're so good with like diving in
and healing back the layers you did that
last time and actually I had a couple at
least one Epiphany in the last time we
met that was something I didn't even
quite get until we I left that space but
uh I want to just go as far as humanly
possible and I have
this aching desire to want to always go
further and to push myself into like
some Zone that doesn't make sense but I
don't know you may have to get Kelly up
she she may give a better answer let's
do that but I I will offer this and I
think and please correct me if this is
at all off base I think there's
something inside of you that owns and
knows that you're very good at this like
it's not the normal person who you know
a couple days into this decides like who
looks around at the other competitors
and says yeah these people they're not
going to beat me like and just knows it
and maybe that's Wolverine but that's
also
Harvey and so I think you know that you
have this in you and you know it's
special and there's something really
beautiful about honoring that and that's
okay you know and it is exciting to see
if you can go further than anyone else
and to explore the outer edges of what
happens to your body and your mind when
you go further than anybody else ever
has I'm still exploring it it's still
like I just I think you're right you've
said things that that's that are true
like you're absolutely right there's
there's more layers to it but I'm M also
sort of multifaceted in a sense I may be
feeling one area like at some time I
might be having that hunting phase where
I'm like lured myself in the back and
I'm just observing every every single
possible detail of every person at like
a level that no one realizes are
happening and then there's other times
where I'm just in there and enjoying
like a great conversation and like we're
totally working as a team like the the
third night there was like seven of us
that ran many of the loops to finish as
a unit at 300 miles and like for me
running as that unit um brought me such
uh
incredible it's pretty cool that's ay so
cool because uh there were some of these
Runners that were like like they were on
their way out but because we like worked
as a team and like I called the the go
when to go and when to slow like I so
like we would like run to a certain
point I said okay now we're going to
like walk for like 20 seconds relax
yourself you guys are doing I just say
you guys are doing amazing keep moving
okay we're gonna get this now I say okay
uh we're going to start running again
when we run and I was just like speaking
to the group most of the time and like
just calling it out to me that was fun
it was like being like a commander of a
group but as a myself every single
person there added energy to me it was
like animals moving in nature like I
mean animals moving in nature move more
efficiently than in individuals so like
there was a strategic element to that as
well I wasn't thinking of like you know
taking out the person next to me I was
thinking of all of us are moving further
together and we're like actually working
as a unit and this is freaking amazing
that we get to 300 miles you know 3
years earlier no one had even made it to
300 miles now we we had 22 people make
it to 300 miles and seven of them were
in our group so it was so cool that was
probably one of my favorite experiences
of the whole race was running in that
unit yeah yeah that is cool it was fun
let's get the truth let's get let's get
Kelly up here and uh we're going to put
all your [__] to the test there you
go welcome thank you thanks for an honor
to be here have you ever done a podcast
before no not like this all right well
welcome uh let all of this like
disappear nice little surprise I'm
delighted to have you here let's just
begin with uh if if you're giving Harvey
uh a report card on the veracity of what
he shared like what's how's he doing
what do we not know what what hasn't
come up what who's the real Harvey here
I would have to give him a C+ was there
SK I thought it was like at least a
minus or something maybe B minus maybe
minus it no he's I think he's still
figuring himself out a lot so when he
kind of I feel like dances around
questions sometimes and you do a very
good job at bringing him back to the
original question I think a lot of it is
he is still searching for what's inside
of him um there's also a reason why I'm
still with Harvey after over 10 years I
want to understand
this a unque you guys have a unique
relationship and we do I'm still trying
to figure him out I guess is what I'm
saying too and I think that's one of the
biggest attractions is I learn something
new about him almost daily so if you had
to answer the why question or if
somebody asked you like why does Harvey
do this like what is what's beneath the
surface I would say that when he talks
about wanting to make a difference in
other people's life I would say that is
pretty much the number one reason I can
see that it truly truly is I've never
met anybody and he's never said this I'm
just saying this from what I take from
him I I seriously think he just wants to
leave this world a better place and
anything he can do to bring more
goodness um positivity um if he can help
others discover what they're capable of
doing that's his life goal like that's
what he wants to do and certainly
running further and longer than anyone
else it's just as good away as any other
it's a good place to
start stage I got yeah yeah well that's
the card you're playing right it's a
good card yeah and you know I think uh
you are correct when you say that he's
this like lovable you know kind human um
me and my daughter joke we always say
we're going to get a bumper sticker
made that says I break for lightning
bugs because we have gotten Whiplash
before when because we've been driving
on a back road and a lightning bug flies
in our path and he's got a break really
hard so we don't no I don't do that all
the time now yeah the Harvey that people
see is they see Runner Harvey and school
teacher Harvey people don't get to see
Harvey as my partner which is I mean
it's who he is but it's like a whole
other piece that nobody gets to see and
what is that like I mean you I mean
you're an ultr Runner yourself right so
you understand this lifestyle and you're
engaged with it just the same and you
have this unique relationship because
you don't necessarily live together all
the time right yeah so we've been
together for over 10 years we don't live
together we live about an hour and 45
minutes apart and I can honestly say
that Harvey's training has never impeded
our relationship which is huge is that
because you're training with him or
because he's he's so accomodating so
conscious of and when he says when he
says he doesn't have a plan when he gets
up for like what he's going to do that
day he's he's serious that is where we
differ in training because I am more
okay Monday I've got to run this many
miles and I've got to run at this pace
and Harvey is more like okay so I'm
feeling like 20 feels good today but I'm
going to do my 20 here here and here so
it doesn't affect any of our plans for
for the day I don't feel like training
has ever impeded um us and in in the
teen years that we've been together he
drives to Circleville every weekend and
in over 10 years never once never one
time has he said Kelly I'm really busy
this weekend and I've got a lot of stuff
to do and I'm not going to make it up to
Circleville and that is huge yeah that's
that's interesting that's and what yeah
so those are so my heart is wared my
heart is warmed in Fair Monday through
Friday this guy can is like running all
the time and like teaching and that's
pretty much it right I imagine it's
fairly monastic during the week for you
yeah so I kind of really consider is
like I I 100% live in two different
places I live with you you know three
nights a week and and in Cincinnati four
nights a week and uh so yeah like for
the last like five or so years I've been
really involved with also taking care of
my mother uh so that would be a couple
nights a week uh in Cincinnati and we
just moved her to Maryland to be near my
sister but otherwise my teaching day and
I do a lot of like running related stuff
you're right Monday through Thursday
every other thing like friends and stuff
like that and that's another thing that
people don't see of you is that up until
just October two days a week you were
driving 40 minutes round trip to go care
for your mother and not just stop in hey
Mom how are you um Mom let's get up and
let's go for a walk let's go to the
store let's go out to eat eat let's
socialize um so two days a week you also
were doing that yeah it was busy busy
basically I need to abandon this Quest
that I'm on to like uncover the darkness
here like there this is like Harvey is
as you see him right like and more which
is you know I have hope for Humanity
thank you for that I do I truly do I I
really I feel like he is everything that
everybody sees and so much more thank
you that's very sweet well um we were
going for the record for the longest
engagement but we actually like have put
a date on on our our wedding day now
it's like wow June 1st like yeah so
we're actually getting married um but
we've really been
like practically we've been married like
years so long know right you're just
turning the engagement into it own Ultra
take our
time but uh we actually met in the North
Coast 2 hour race we met in a 24-hour
race and Kelly is always uh very
supportive of me so I I couldn't do the
types of things I do without her like
encouragement like being on on my team
even if she's not there you know she may
think that some of my ideas are a little
delusional at times perhaps but but she
always is supporting me so you know like
when I was doing that Big's backyard
another thing that gave me like ump you
I mentioned some of the things already
but like Jud is like telling me hey
Kelly and Carly our rescue dog are out
running this morning and just by the
fact that they're out running you know
and I'm on my fourth day like I could
like kind of connect with that energy
and it just it definitely made me feel
better it just made me feel like you
know they well we're both running
different places on the country but
we're both like it's a connective energy
which is really nice and what's your
relationship to Ultras and race in these
days like what does that look like um
I've been running ultas for let's see I
think my first one was in
2011 yeah that sound about right and I
think we met in
2013 yeah so I've done uh 24-hour races
100 mile races I ran badwater in 2022
you had a remarkable experience with
badar because it was like just making it
each cut off by like literally a minute
by seconds in some places and I mean she
hallucinated she had like every reason
was there to like have quit multiple
times yeah but I had this phenomenal
crew phenomenal and it's something about
Kelly also is like her training doesn't
necessarily always come together but for
whatever reason she is a very strong
with executing the race it's like some
people they train really really amazing
get all together and then like they get
to a race and it just doesn't happen
like she's the opposite like she her
training can just be raveled and like I
mean before Oh my God and I'm like wow
and it's not necessarily like maybe some
injury happens or this or that but then
you get to the race and you are just
like a machine you're like I am going to
finish I know and then I'm always like
wow what I wonder how I would do if I
could actually like have a solid
training block yeah that's so
interesting uh you the person who's so
regimented about their training though
tend to be the people who are less
resilient when things go wrong in the
middle of a race right because it's a
control thing and to have the
wherewithal to go into a race knowing
that your training wasn't great and
still execute is illustrative of
somebody who has a tremendous amount of
resilience water's no no joke no joke no
joke I mean I seriously and I had been
out there for years prior to me even
applying and running so I knew that I
was was getting myself into but then
there was this small part of me that
thought maybe it's not that bad maybe it
really the hype of the Heat and you know
just all of it maybe it's not that bad
oh my gosh no it's terrible the whole
thing is terrible was so hard it was so
hard and I have experience with Ultras
and the biggest thing that threw me for
such a loop out there was the depth
perception so you would run for hours
and hours and hours and the mountains
would never get closer or this little
line that goes through this mountain
over to the side is still there 20 miles
later I look over oh my goodness there's
that line so the depth perception is the
one thing that really threw me for Loop
Panamint coming off of Town's P you see
Panamint in the distance it's like it
takes forever to get to it well good for
you I want to talk about the squid game
thing but before we transition to that
just so we're
clear nothing else about Harvey that
like we need to know that the that the
you know that the passer by wouldn't
understand any fast ones that that he
pulled in the middle of the interview
where you felt like that's no come on
Harvey it's okay honey yeah I'm thinking
I was making I was making so many mental
notes when I was listening I do like oh
what did Rich say he said something and
I'm like think okay Harvey come on now
and I you never I can't remember what it
was though shoot yeah maybe it'll come
to me in a minute but um yeah I gave him
a C+ a B minus somewhere between there
because I I think you're still figuring
things out as well and what what drives
me what drives you I'm still trying to
figure out what drives you so were you
surprised when I won that race the 450
mies like good question you were
watching this from hold on this is
coming back now this is coming back now
okay so rich said to you and I if you
remember correctly right when we were
having lunch prior to coming here I
asked you the exact same question I said
but those other people that are out in
the race they also think they're going
to win they're also going for the win
you're also going for the win What Makes
You Different and you asked that you
said what differentiates you from the
others you know they could be looking
all around saying oh I'm taking you all
down you you're all done and you're
looking at everybody as the Wolverine
and you're taking everybody down so what
makes you different and I asked you that
exact same question before we came here
and you still you cannot that was only
like day two The Wolverine yeah but you
a lot of people ask me about Harvey's
training that's what that's what people
typically want to know about you know
how many miles does he run a week how
often does he do Hills what's to speed
work like I can't answer any of that and
he probably can't either
because yeah it's interesting and
refreshing you know especially on social
media it's all about what's your morning
routine and you know exactly what is
your Zone to and all these people get
really obsessed with the minutia of the
lifestyle habits of high performing
people but in my experience a lot not
all but a lot of the most elite people
in their respective disciplines and
Fields
have a very different relationship with
those kinds of things that's much more
intuitive in nature and not regimented
in the way that one might be led to
believe if you're watching a lot of
reals on Instagram uh you know from
people who are not Elite telling you
what they learned or what you should do
or should not do with respect to certain
things and uh I think there's I don't
know what the lesson in that is but I
think there is a lesson in that yeah and
I think it's your mind and it's your
psychology
uh that I think separates him from
others well Laz said it you're the guy
who won't give up so I think it's more
honey badger than
Monarch uh on some level like it's that
you know like not a death grip has a
pejorative kind of connotation but like
you're latching on to something and you
have the tenacity to not let go until
you achieve your desired outcome I think
something else about you that a lot of
people may not know is that for as long
as I've known you he may have H he may
have a goal going into a race whether
it's like a distance or a time goal I've
never seen him disappointed I've never
seen him upset over like oh if I would
have just done that I could have I could
have gotten this time or if I would have
just done that I could have maybe you
know been in second place then third
place he celebrates every single thing
he does everything if he doesn't hit a
goal in a race I don't think he looks at
at it as a failure I think he looks at
it as you know moving forward if I want
to do something different I I can just
tweak something but every finish is a
celebration to him would you say that's
right I think for the most part I mean
it's uh I try to find like some positive
and everything and then but also like if
I don't do as well as I want to that's
actually can be really powerful as well
so for example like with Australia I
like finished third and like things fell
apart in a way like you know with the
going through the Deep hallucinations
and it was powerful because it caused me
to want to grow so like after that I
actually changed some things some things
real small like I started taking cold
showers the whole month leading up to
baks I did cold showers and I'm still
doing them now like only cold showers
tell the truth about cold showers what
what's the truth I the truth is you only
take a cold shower on the days you don't
take hot baths yeah that's true so I do
take hot
baths you we go got check some balances
here this is what I was looking for all
right keep
going but you know it's it's like the
that actually motivated me to elevate
like the you know different things
within my training like uh mileage a bit
more like thinking through what did I
mess up with in terms of like maybe my
rtion or like uh my motivation my mind
where my mind traveled to my pacing all
the strategies like I thought those
through finishing third in Australia and
I set an American record doing that like
finished with 375 miles so I was like I
was grateful that I got that and I was
also grateful to see Phil Gore get the
new record because I felt like I was a
part of that so even though I finished
third I was delighted that Phil
like overcame and got the world record
like I felt like I was a part of the
team that helped him get there so like
for me that was a success beautiful like
and it was it was a a celebration
Australia but it's like everything we do
uh sometimes things don't go the way we
expect them to go that's that's okay
because then it determines how we take
that event determines where we'll go
with it you can like take that and let
it destroy you you can beat yourself
down for something you you did or you
can take that and say okay I'm going to
use that to motivate myself to to work
harder to like learn new tactics to like
grow into so I mean I feel like that is
important element yeah the two lessons
that I extract from that are one when
you make it about something more than
yourself I.E celebrating your friend or
you know having the gratitude for
contributing to his record that
ameliorates the The Sting of defeat
because it's not about you and your ego
it's about more than that which keeps
you in the sport longer and keeps it
fresh and interesting and encouraging no
matter the result and then the second
lesson being this capacity or reflex to
develop the muscle of being enthusiastic
about what you learn when things don't
go your way and being stoked about it
like oh my God it didn't go my way but
look what I got out of this and I can
apply this next time as opposed to the
self-defeating you know kind of impulse
to beat yourself up and feel bad because
you didn't reach your goal and I think
those are lessons that are applicable no
matter what you're trying to achieve in
your life and as a cross country coach
finding that why finding something
that's bigger than you because you'll
always give yourself permission to quit
if you just leave it up to you you can
almost always find a reason to say you
know what this is really uncomfortable
like I'm going to back down but when you
have something that's bigger than you
it's harder to let other people down so
I always encouraged my athletes to find
something that was outside of them that
they could rely on when it got tough out
there in a 5k or when the weather was
you know not ideal and they still had to
race so I think finding that why and
finding that reason that's you know
bigger than you is and also you touched
on it earlier when you said about like
when it gets bad you find like Harvey
being Wolverine or a spirit animal I
used to have my athletes like really do
some research and find somebody that
they find you know either a great
athlete or somebody that they think very
highly of and you know when it gets
tough out there that's when you're going
to kind of Let Yourself Go and think
okay so what would so and so do you know
and how would Harvey Lewis run up this
hill or how would you know whoever they
admired how would that person tackle
this hill so I think getting out of your
own body is something that I feel he
does really well at and I just think
it's kind of the key to pushing through
hard times for sure let's talk about
squid game okay so squid game was the
international phenomenon on on Netflix
the show that swept the world and
rewrote the ratings books in in terms of
uh you know audience share I mean the
whole world was talking about that TV
show then there was this reality show
game show concept that you found
yourself involved in so I'm I need to
know what
this is like this came out of left field
I saw Harvey shared a video I was like
wait what
like yeah and the interesting thing
about it is uh we recorded it in January
of 2023 so I couldn't talk about
anything until now till it was releas so
I've been holding on to all this you
know information for you know a year now
so yeah uh squid game came out in
2021 I believe and um it was the most
watched Netflix series to date and it
was shown in 94 countries and then in
2022 they decided they were Netflix was
going to produce a reality show based on
the original squid game so it was called
squid game The Challenge and it was
going to be all the games and everything
was going to be based on the original
one so it was kind of cool to be
involved with it it was the largest
casted reality show in the history of TV
with the largest prize pot of
$456
million to the have all the cash in a in
like a loose sight Cube hanging from the
ceiling like in the show they did how
did you get involved with this so this
is how I got involved with it I'm not
even really a big TV Watcher but we did
get started on squid game when it came
out and it's kind of dark and I seem to
kind of be drawn to those psychological
type of Thriller type shows so I loved
it uh I don't Harvey is not really no I
like the show I love the show you did
yeah the Korean like culture all that
and the competition was very interesting
um
anyway they started casting for the
reality show and it was my 20-year-old
son that actually had sent me the link
and said you should apply for this and I
think what had happened he went to apply
for it but she had to be 21 so the next
best thing would be his mom you shot one
video just one video so he sent me the
link on a whim I sat down came back from
running I just got back from running
like four or five miles I was like oh
yeah I got this link clicked on it
filled out the application online I shot
one 60-second video like in one take and
I watched it and I'm like yep good
enough send it on it's just those things
I thought oh I'll send off I'll probably
never hear anything within 24 hours um a
casting agent from La had texted me and
we did a phone interview and then it
just kind of snowballed from there so it
was a super indepth um process the whole
vetting took from August of 2022 until
December of 2022 just the vetting part
yeah so four months yeah so full
background check back pychological
psychological evaluation social media
check a lot of stuff big deal so it was
filmed in London in January of 2023 so
they flew 456 of us over to London where
we were isolated 3 to 4 days prior to
filming in our hotel rooms so we weren't
allowed to talk to each other we could
only come out of our hotel room like
three times a day to get our pick up our
food and then we started filming they
put us all on these coach buses and bust
us to the middle of this field with
these two big old military hangers and
that's where it all started wow and they
took you through the challenges just the
way they unfold pretty much in the show
without the dying part yes without the
dying part but they try to simulate it
as best as they could so we had we did
have these um like ink packs on so we
were to to get eliminated they would uh
activate our pack and it would explode
so then like you know this dark ink
would kind of bleed out onto our
shirt no spoilers everybody should watch
the show the show's doing really well on
Netflix like we're recording this in
December but I checked maybe a handful
of days ago and it was like in the top
10 shows still so a lot of people are
watching this show are you getting like
stopped do people recognize you now cuz
you're in this TV show well you know I
teach middle school so of my middle
schoolers are like hey there's that
teacher that was in Squid game
unbelievable so that's fun yeah and I
have got stopped at the local pharmacy
actually when we were getting ready to
leave but they were like
hey so yeah it was interesting it was
fun you had a good time they're casting
for season two oh they're doing it again
wow would you ever a reality
show uh no I don't think so no I always
said no that was publicly exposed enough
you I don't need I don't need any more
of that I'm fulfilled with this form of
media I think I'm okay with it that was
the first time that I had applied to a
reality show it's got to be
disorienting to go someplace be isolated
sort of like you're on jury duty and you
just get busted around you have no
control over your life yes and also
because it's reality TV of course
they're manipulating things and you
realize like oh this isn't a documentary
this
is this is its own entirely you know
unique thing but the sets were amazing I
mean when you would walk into a set it
was literally like stepping onto the set
of the movie squid game I would assume
that on some level you were cast because
of your background in endurance
Athletics how did that come into play
for better or worse as a contestant I
think without giving too much much way I
think it helped and it hindered me in
some situations but definitely when I
was there all I kept thinking is like I
ran through Death Valley and it was 124
degrees Yeah no one else here did that
nobody else yeah I'm the honey badger
Monarch Wolverine in this surv that cold
hanger for quite some time right yeah so
that was difficult there were people
that were passing out near you there was
a couple people pass out in that that
particular it was yeah the
definitely in the first game was it was
rough for sure it was cold it was very
cold yeah and you'll see it in the first
well just it just bumped to the top of
my queue I'll check it out we've been
going a long time and I got to let you
guys get back to your life but I I do
want to kind of end with a couple quick
questions I mean Jesse as I mentioned
you know shared a few questions one of
the things that he wanted to know was
you Harvey being the Superman of running
how do you handle lazy people in your
inner circle that is a great
question because you're a very
compassionate man yeah yeah so I mean
Hon you're not a lazy man no no I try to
try to find like a little way to try to
like nudge people in a in a positive way
so it depends on the situation like if
I'm in school like I know I have to be
careful with kids and like leave them
with more positives I have friends
growing up that had a teacher say
something like you'll never amount to
anything like that's outrageous like for
someone to say something like that I
want to be very encouraging with my
words like where I like am dealing with
like students like I want to like nudge
them in a way that like motivates them
now if it's one of my close friends and
they're being lazy or someone in my
inner
circle ah
over house I do try to like I'm just
like we're going to go do some some
walking we're going to get this is where
I say he does it in a manipulative way
manipulative honey with a smile on his
face right uh no for example okay honey
if I'm tired and I'm like oh you're not
lazy you're never lazy hone I don't feel
like being lazy I swear in the next two
minutes he will say something like so I
talked to Mike Fremont
yesterday you know you're reading into
that wrong I would never say about you
honey and I I swear this is how Harvey
does it it's like he that's the nudge
that's the nud passive aggressive
sometimes I don't think so some in a
good way right all right that's a good
answer though I'm satisfied with that
answer okay um in the Hollywood movie of
Harvey Lewis's life we're gonna play a
little casting couch here who plays
Harvey in the
movie this is my question not Jess are
you asking her Kelly or well take a take
don't tell me you haven't thought about
it that's so bad
oh well I mean honestly I think Matthew
mccy is like he's he's just hilarious I
love like like his right energy for you
yeah he's he's really great with that so
I mean I I would like I
mean yeah that would be incredible but
uh I honey what what do you think K
who's playing Harvey
you're the casting director he's so
Dynamic he can transcend different
characters
like that's a
good sometimes I think of like uh John
heer from Napoleon Dynamite oh there we
goone there's there's a knuckle ball
your
direction I know you do I know you do
fine a little bit of a different energy
from the mciss sense yeah yeah I don't I
don't know that Matthew MCC is but I I
say that just because of like he's kind
of quirky and even him and the movie
about oh it's a baseball oh Bench
Warmers Bench Warmers that's it like he
just has his quirkiness and that's a
side that a lot of people don't see of
you that I love and it's
this I don't know like you just say
weird things like that's great honey you
say things like hey like how many times
have you came do you guys want to have
like a popsicle party or something
tonight popsic party and my kids and
myself we're like I don't think I've
done that in a little while we're
like I love is it 1950 What El oh my
gosh I can tell you so many things that
he says and my kids look at me and
they're like you know Mark Walberg I
think he'd be pretty good too you'll be
pretty good he's gonna have to trim down
a little I'm going have to work on yeah
right or you're GNA have to you're going
have to be I saw that Napoleon film and
uh you know that was actually quite
amazing you know film too but there was
a preview that he's in this new film now
where he's doing these Adventure races
and he's got this dog uh it's coming out
in the next few months I could relate in
the sense of our dog like Carly is my
number one training partner like our
rescue dog Carly so a lot of people
don't know that that our dog is like she
has got such incredible energy and like
her her mindset like that dog will never
turn like she defends the front of house
like there could be a Tyrannosaurus Rex
and she would just go straight after it
without a doubt and it's like this dog
is like this tall but it's from her
pound days like she is just amazing and
like for her running is an absolute gift
every time we run she's so she just
loves running so much like I don't know
anybody on the planet that likes running
as much as Carly so like when we run
together we're out in the country in the
Middle nowhere we're just having so much
fun just running as hard as we can at
times or just cruising along s and it's
just a blast yeah like so wallberg
because he did this
movie I got two I thought about this a
little bit one would
be a younger Billy Bob
Thorton little dark he's a little some
Darkness there though you know I don't
know if that matches up so I balance
that out with a young Ron Howard CU
there's a little Richie Cunningham in
you I think too yeah what do you think
oh yeah I mean
M yeah what are you GNA do right soad
well you know all right that's so bad um
final thing I spent a lot of time
thinking
about about the nature of change why
some people are able to change others
aren't why some are able to set goals
and Achieve them and others struggle how
do you think about you know we've talked
a lot
about human capacity and the fact that
we all have latent potential within us
that goes untapped and you're kind of on
the outer edges of trying to see where
that limit might be for yourself and
that speaks to the broader issue of our
all of our capacities and I think that's
your greatest influence is getting us to
reimagine what we might be capable of in
our own lives so to the person who does
struggle with this who's trying to level
up or shoulder responsibility for a
positive change in their life like how
do you get that
person activated and on the right track
towards sustainable positive
change right now is really timing
because we're coming to the end of the
year moving into the new year and every
year I like
to it's kind of like your month that you
take away I think and and reset yourself
I like to to Really uh put out there a
list of goals I have for the year ahead
like and it could be you know a couple
goals for me it's like 10 or 12 goals
and like those are the
real like points I want to really invest
time and like finding a routine so
routine is so critical whatever you
start for two days three days it's not
yet a routine but once you get into like
that second week you've established a
new routine so just start with having
some time alone with yourself in a place
that you can really get into that deep
thought and and you can start this any
time of the year but having maybe it's
easiest to start with a few goals but
start with those goals and then show up
show up each week if you miss a week
that's okay like yoga for example uh
Kelly started yoga and she's been having
trouble with her back that's kind of led
to her knee and like that yoga like
doing that once or twice a week has been
super powerful and like it's really
helped to alleviate some of your
discomfort and uh you know we missed
yoga maybe this week or last week I
don't remember um but then you know it's
not going to stop us from like the next
week of picking that back up so finding
those powerful routines I'm a person
that's like ADHD I also sometimes run
from like uh being a typ a like super
dialed in with every single thing having
to be a certain way but on the other
hand I also see the power of the
routines so like every Monday going into
bigs I had started the yoga and like the
yoga is really powerful because it's not
something I I routinely do but in the
like five or six weeks leading up it was
also helping with like the mental aspect
and so putting down those goals and I
feel like writing them down is is is so
powerful and even telling someone you
trust is so powerful because then it
holds you more accountable than if it's
just in your mind mind and it's sort of
fleeting when you write it down and then
it's somewhere where you see it like it
might be in your calendar your planner
or maybe somewhere on the wall it's
powerful and I feel like having
something that we're driving towards
each year that's involves some level
growth somewhere with relationships or
with work or with our Athletics or or
wherever it is like that's that's really
a something that will give you more back
and so that's where I would start with
him mhm I think with people like that
are struggling with getting a routine
cuz I think it starts before that easy
to say like you know get into a routine
of doing this but something else comes
right before that and that's taking the
action to do it and I think a lot of
people are waiting for motivation or
they're waiting for that feeling of like
well once I feel like I want to do this
you know then I'll start my biggest
thing that I've taken away when I've
coached students and adult ad is don't
wait for the motivation because that's a
fleeting feeling and we can't always
control the way we feel so you have to
just show up whether and that's the one
thing I think you have to make that
commitment to yourself with yourself
that even when I feel like I don't want
to go here even when I feel like I don't
want to get out of bed 45 minutes
earlier than normal I'm going to make
that commitment to myself right now that
I'm still going to do it and that's
where I think a lot of people falter
when they come to like having to create
a routine or make a routine or set goals
is that they're always like but I don't
feel like doing this but then once that
routine gets established that's when you
feel Euphoria and you feel good and you
feel better about yourself so I I think
that would be mine would be that you
know having people understand that you
don't always have to feel motivated to
go do this and you're not so very good
advice yes in fact how you feel about
doing the thing really shouldn't have
anything to do with the doing of the
thing
itself I beat this drum all the time
mood follows action or to quote Dr
Andrew huberman action first thoughts
feelings and perceptions follow 100% but
we do have this Instinct where we want
to wait until we feel like doing the
thing and we also want to know how it's
going to play out we want to know what
that road map is going to look like and
where and when the destination will be
arrived upon and you don't get to have
that that's a privilege that doesn't
exist Journey so developing that reflex
to action or that inclination towards
action irrespective of how you feel
about it is the thing that gets you out
of bed when you don't want to get out of
bed or out the door when it's freezing
cold or raining or you know choose your
adventure absolutely so
yeah you agree with that Harvey I'd say
so yeah it's like uh I don't know I
struggle with this with my students I
want all my students to succeed in like
like my buddy Greg Armstrong he's a
science teacher down in Tennessee and
like just he gets kids out in
experiential learning I mean he's taking
kids to Africa or to Central America
every three months and he even built an
ampi theater in the back of their school
by hand with his students I mean it's
like those sort of experiential learning
they have like a powerful impact when
you get to go and like uh interact with
someone who's like living in a
developing country with no access to
water and like they're building these
well water with the run for water it's
like that has some sort of spark that
goes even Beyond these yeah yeah yeah
that's a yeah I think that's a really
that's an insightful kind of C out to
this whole thing I mean I think what
Kelly's talking about is how do you
develop the resourcefulness to welcome
discomfort into your life and and you're
really speaking to the idea of how do
you get somebody really excited about
the Journey of learning and expanding
your kind the aperture of your life
experience right and as somebody who's
every day dealing with young minds and
thinking about how do I get this person
interested or excited about this
material there's an emotional connection
that you have to create and immersive
experiential situations are obviously
going to engender that and there is
something lasting about that that can
then create a trajectory for for a young
person so I think that is a really
insightful thought I think we did it I
think we did I think we're done thank
you so how you feel yeah I feel amazing
honestly it was a
blast I was a total surprise like we had
no idea that Kelly was going to hop
thank you for uh leaping in the chair
never did this you never have good it's
therapetic it is very therapeutic like
it's it's like
uh he really he's an amazing person I
mean he he mails me letters he'll mail
me a card in the like I'll just go you
are not lazy honey I'll never and all
say no you you do keeps getting better
hary start looking better better I
thought you were going to come on here I
was like come on let me tell you dite
and then you just shine a brighter light
on this guy I know I know but I really I
mean I do know I mean there are some
other things like but for the most part
no yeah we'll be on vacation and like a
month later I'll check my mail and I'll
have like a postcard from where Harvey
sent me a a postcard while we were on
vacation together like I'm having a
great time with you in wherever we're at
and I'm just like who does this all
right well hurry up and get married you
guys right um Harvey congratulations
like just you know so much respect for
for not just these extraordinary
athletic Feats but but really how you
comport yourself as a human being and
the way that you exude the values that
are important to you and you know I
really do think it's heroic and it is
the type and archetype of hero that we
need now more than ever in this weird
divided world that we find ourselves in
and what you do cuts through that noise
you know it really is a signal in the
noise and I appreciate you I'm here to
support you you are my spirit animal I'm
not going with the monarch of the honey
I'm going with the said when I said
you're a hero like honestly like I
remember listening to your podcast as
I'm out there running long runs and just
you have been able to do things that are
amazing I mean fact that you've had like
the number of people you've had on this
just the realm of different like
backgrounds like it's just incredible so
I mean it's fun journey I ran into a
runner this morning like up on the
mountain I was coming down she was going
up and Kimberly from Virginia and she's
like uh oh yeah I love rich I love rich
and what he did for his daughter was
amazing for her birthday that's you just
celebrated her birthday yeah so I mean
it's like you you're hitting people
after our episode the last one I went to
Cyprus like for spring break like a few
months after that and like in Cypress
there were like all these people in
Cyprus they had oh yeah we love the rich
R episode oh yeah and so it's crazy that
can you imagine it you have people in
like over a 100 countries like listening
to you it's great freaks me out a little
bit it's really wild man get in my head
or whatever this is a team effort
obviously as you can see everyone just
sees the black curtains but you know
it's not just
me
that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change in
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. richr
if you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason Cameo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davey Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt traper Patt
and Harry mathys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace plants
[Music]
namaste